في المقابل اكد وزير الدفاع الروسيه ان
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه فشلت في اختراق
الدفاعات الروسيه في محور زبر روشا وقال
في اجتماع الهيئه القياديه لوزاره الدفاع
ان القوات الروسيه تتمكنت من اضعاف
القدرات القتاليه الاوكرانيه في منطقه
العمليه العسكريه حسب
قولها
زملائي المحترمين ابدا بالحديث عن الاوضاع
في منطقه العمليه العسكريه الخاصه بفضل
العمل النشط لقواتنا تمكنا من اضعاف
القدره القتاليه للعدو والحقنا به اضرارا
جسيمه وحدات مجموعه الجنوب صدت كل الهجمات
في محور السوليدار باخمد جميع محاولات
العدو لاختراق دفاعاتنا في
بلدتينو على محور زابوروجيا بات بالفشل
انضموا الينا من زبروج مراسل الجزيره
الياس كرام الياس كيف يتطور الهجوم المضاد
خاصه في زبروج
من الواضح بان الهجوم الاوكراني في محور
زبالوجيا متعثر منذ اسابيع عده بعد ان
كانت القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه قد اعلنت
بانها اخترقت خط الدفاع الاول للقوات
الروسيه في تلك المنطقه ذلك ان الجيش
الاوكراني مازال يتحدث عن خوضه لمعارك
وقتال وهجوم معاكس من جانب القوات الروسيه
على نفس المحوري ذاته قرب بلدتي برفيفي
وروبوتين هذه هذا المحور الذي تقوم فيه جل
المعارك ما بين الطرفين ومن الواضح بان
القوات الروسيه كما نفهم من بيانات الجيش
الاوكراني تحاول توسيع مناطق الصراع
ومناطق الاشتباك مع القوات الاوكرانيه
وعدم حصرها في هذه النقطه تحديدا اي عند
وهذا ما يفسر اعلان الجيش الاوكراني في
الايام الماضيه بانه صدها هجمات عند
اوراجينا هذه البلده التي تبدو اقرب الى
منطقه الدومباس وايضا عند بلده نوفو
داريفكا هذه البلده التي تقع على منتصف
الطريق ما بين هذه الجبهه الممتده على
مئات الكيلومترات من الدنباس وحتى في
محاوله كما يبدو من جانب القوات الروسيه
لاشغال الجيش الاوكراني في اكثر من موقع
في اشتباكات وهجمات متعدده واشغاله عن خط
الهجوم الرئيسي هنا في منطقه حيث يقوم
الجيش الاوكراني بدفع مزيد من التعزيزات
العسكريه الى تلك المنطقه من ناحيه اخرى
واضح بان الجيش الاوكراني ايضا يتعرض
لضربات من جانب الجيش الروسي في خطوطه
الخلفيه لان الاداره العسكريه في اقليم
زبالوجيا تتحدث عن ان اثنتين وعشرين بلده
في هذا المحور تعرضت في الساعات 24
الاخيره الى قصف جوي وقصف مدفعي روسي
باشكال مختلفه وهذا يعني بان القوات هي
بدات تضرب ايضا الخطوط الخلفيه اي خطوط
الامداد للقوات الاوكرانيه التي تاتي عند
هذه البلدات من محور زبروجيا جنوبا وهذا
ما يضعف كما يبدو او يؤخر ويبطئ تقدم
القوات الاوكرانيه تحديدا في هذا المحور
القوات الروسيه تشن وهجمات عند اوريخوف
وماليه
وغيرها من البلدات في هذا المحور وهي
بلدات تبعد يعني بضعه كيلومترات الى
الشمال من موقع الهجوم الرئيسي للجيش
الاوكراني في تلك المنطقه من ناحيه اخرى
نرى بان القوات الخاصه الاوكرانيه تقول
بانها كبدت الجيش الروسي خسائر في
المدرعات من خلال هجوم نوعيه باتجاه بعض
المدرعات العسكريه هذا الهجوم هو عمليا
يتكرر في اكثر من منطقه في في هذا الجانب
هذا هو عمليا طبيعه الهجمات وطبيعه الهجوم
المتركز في محور زباروجيا الجيش الروسي يق
وم بضربه المواقع الخلفيه ومواقع تمركز
القوات الاوكرانيه والقوات الاوكرانيه ترد
بالمثل على الجانب الروسي وبالتالي يبدو
ان الهجوم متعثر من ناحيه الاوكرانيين
وايضا من ناحيه الروس لا يبدو ان
الدفاعاتهم قد انهارتهم لك